next month the Los Angeles jury will
decide whether the serial killer known
as the Hollywood Ripper should get the
death penalty in August Michael Gargiulo
was convicted of the murders of two
women and the attempted murder of a
third 48-hours Maureen Maher has been
investigating the Hollywood Ripper for
more than 10 years her reporting
continues in this week's season premiere
of 48 hours this is a systematic
slaughtering of beautiful women by a
serial killer Hollywood Ashlee eller in
2001 an aspiring fashion designer
stabbed 47 times Ashlee Ellerman was
supposed to go on a date with Ashton
Kutcher 48 hours consultant and former
federal prosecutor Maryville Jannetty
he rang the doorbell and nobody answered
he saw what he thought was spilled wine
all over the place unfortunately we
later learned that that was her blood
cutter told the jury when he eventually
learned that Ashlee had been murdered he
quote freaked out knowing his
fingerprints were on her door never a
suspect he was concerned about what he
left behind
unlike the killer who very carefully
covered his tracks
Maria Bruno 2005 a mother of four young
children stabbed to death the killer
leaving only a blue surgical bootie
outside the scene and Santa Monica three
years later an attack on Michelle Murphy
but she survived
Michael Gargiulo always lived near his
victims so he could watch them
prosecutors say the stalking gave him a
sexual thrill since Gargiulo surest in
2008 48 hours has been investigating the
serial killer in the late 90s he came to
Hollywood trying to be an actor
this is his audition tape your name
Michael oh he was cast as a boxer but
Marco Hoffman once a close friend of
Michael gargola says there was something
strange about him he would go online
whatever he could find about forensics
and he would learn you know how to get
away with a crime
back then Gargiulo was also a bouncer
with timur Leary and Anthony D Lorenzo
it was a tough guy absolutely she has
some good punches to him
after I began reporting on this case in
2011 Timur leery revealed to me that
Gargiulo had bragged about killing a
young woman outside Chicago that turned
out to be Trisha Picacho believed by
prosecutors to be his first victim and
marina are joined us now good morning
good morning Michael Gard Julie was
convicted last month why why hasn't he
been sentenced yet well they're waiting
for the death penalty phase in this case
the family members and others will be
called back in to testify on the stand
and the jury comes back and then they
make a decision based on the testimony
from the prosecution and the defense if
they recommend the death penalty but
there's a problem in California governor
Newsom has a moratorium on the death
penalty so they're still trying to
figure out the language and how to deal
with these cases you talked about
Michelle Murphy she's survived has she
spoken out or any of the other victims
families spoken out about no one has
spoken publicly why do you think and
that is because the case is technically
not over and there's still witnesses but
I know for a fact from one of the
California family members they're very
much looking forward to finally being
able to talk to each other because the
prosecution has asked them to please
keep to themselves because they are
witnesses in the case
I just don't think anyone thought it
would take 11 years to get them but when
the death penalty happens the the phase
of it they'll all be in the same place
on the same day same time what can you
tell us about Gargiulo he looks very
different compared to I didn't recognize
yeah so he shaved his head and he's
changed his look several times and one
interesting note he had a wedding ring
on the whole time during the trial and
we could not get an answer from the
defense who is he married to and we
heard afterwards that he has a
relationship with somebody but he had a
whole image thing going during the
entire trial and a demeanor of just
completely nonplussed so interesting how
he studied forensics Maureen thank ya
you can see Maureen's report the
Hollywood Ripper in a special two-hour
season premiere of 48 hours on Saturday
at 9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS